Let's now see how the baseline
method used by D2Hawkeye
would perform on this data set.
The baseline method
would predict
that the cost bucket
for a patient in 2009
will be the same
as it was in 2008.
So let's create a classification
matrix to compute the accuracy
for the baseline
method on the test set.
So we'll use the table function,
where the actual outcomes are
ClaimsTest$bucket2009,
and our predictions are
ClaimsTest$bucket2008.
The accuracy is the sum of the
diagonal, the observations that
were classified
correctly, divided
by the total number of
observations in our test set.
So we want to add up 110138
+ 10721 + 2774 + 1539 + 104.
And we want to divide
by the total number
of observations in this
table, or the number of rows
in ClaimsTest.
So the accuracy of the
baseline method is 0.68.
Now how about the penalty error?
To compute this, we need to
first create a penalty matrix
in R. Keep in mind
that we'll put
the actual outcomes on the
left, and the predicted outcomes
on the top.
So we'll call it
PenaltyMatrix, which
will be equal to a
matrix object in R.
And then we need
to give the numbers
that should fill up the
matrix: 0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
That'll be the first row.
And then 2, 0, 1, 2, 3.
That'll be the second row.
4, 2, 0, 1, 2 for the third row.
6, 4, 2, 0, 1 for
the fourth row.
And finally, 8, 6, 4,
2, 0 for the fifth row.
And then after the
parentheses, type a comma,
and then byrow = TRUE,
and then add nrow = 5.
Close the parentheses,
and hit Enter.
So what did we just create?
Type PenaltyMatrix
and hit Enter.
So with the previous command,
we filled up our matrix row
by row.
The actual outcomes
are on the left,
and the predicted
outcomes are on the top.
So as we saw in the
slides, the worst outcomes
are when we predict
a low cost bucket,
but the actual outcome
is a high cost bucket.
We still give
ourselves a penalty
when we predict a
high cost bucket
and it's actually a low cost
bucket, but it's not as bad.
So now to compute the penalty
error of the baseline method,
we can multiply our
classification matrix
by the penalty matrix.
So go ahead and hit the
Up arrow to get back
to where you created
the classification
matrix with the table function.
And we're going to surround
the entire table function
by as.matrix to
convert it to a matrix
so that we can multiply
it by our penalty matrix.
So now at the end,
close the parentheses
and then multiply by
PenaltyMatrix and hit Enter.
So what this does is
it takes each number
in the classification
matrix and multiplies it
by the corresponding number
in the penalty matrix.
So now to compute
the penalty error,
we just need to sum
it up and divide
by the number of
observations in our test set.
So scroll up once,
and then we'll
just surround our
entire previous command
by the sum function.
And we'll divide by the
number of rows in ClaimsTest
and hit Enter.
So the penalty error for
the baseline method is 0.74.
In the next video,
our goal will be
to create a CART model that
has an accuracy higher than 68%
and a penalty error
lower than 0.74.